voici le quartier de l'aérostat en cours
de construction au nord de trappes une
nouvelle phase de travaux a débuté ce
matin 62 logements supplémentaires
verront le jour dans un an
les futurs bâtiments seront tous équipés
de balcon ou terrasse un critère
important pour le maire qui veut
favoriser la qualité de vie des
habitants a beaucoup gênés en place une
sorte d'organisation à des moteurs pas
trop importante pour que le ca reste à
taille humaine et pas la défense tu
atterris beaucoup plus calme en tout le
quartier de l'aérostat proposera à 850
nouveaux logements les superficies
varieront du studio au 5 pièces avec
quelques maisons individuelles un
aménagement visant à encourager la
mixité sociale trap a besoin dont je
pense faire évoluer son image et elle le
fait très bien parce que on a ce
quartier là mais il ya eu toute une
restructuration dans d'autres quartiers
également donc c'est une ville en
mouvement avec beaucoup de dynamisme
mais le premier objectif de ce quartier
est de permettre à des foyers aux
revenus modérés d'accéder à la propriété
le prix au mètre carré se situera autour
de 3000 euros et les normes
environnementales devraient garantir une
énergie moins chère
c'est important aussi d'avoir des de
payer moins en terme de chauffage par
exemple parce que selon le type de
population rom accueil
je pense que c'est bien qu'ils puissent
bénéficier de je dirais de paris peu
qu'ils soient abordables pour pour tous
du côté des riverains les avis sont
favorables si certains regrettent le
terrain dans son état nu qui offrait un
espace vert la majorité voient d'un bon
oeil la transformation en cours de leur
ville